here's how you make money from a
multiple of different side hustles you
can re-upload just rain noises and boom
you make thousands of dollars the truth
is back when I was starting out in 2016
that was real back in the day we started
making a lot of money from water bottle
flips I don't know if anyone remembers
that but there was a trend in water
bottle flips where you Tred to get it to
land right and YouTube was not as strict
about compilation so you can monetize
anything so we did make a lot of money
in that method but today YouTube's more
strict they want transformative content
they want it to be a little bit switched
up they want usually a narration on the
content so it doesn't work anymore to
just do compilations you have to be a
little bit more creative with your
content